All good things must come to an end.
And so did the Pax Romana, a 200-year-long
period of time which represented the Roman
Empire at its most glorious and most powerful.
It started with the formation of the empire
under Augustus and ended with the death of
Marcus Aurelius, the last of the so-called
Five Good Emperors.
Marcus Aurelius earned the sobriquet “The
Philosopher King” because he personified
the concept devised by Plato of a ruler who
was a lover of wisdom and who applied the
ideas he learned in his exercise of power.
Marcus Aurelius was a Stoic who believed that
reason and virtue led to eudaimonia, or blessedness.
Despite this, his reign as emperor was far
from enlightened or peaceful.
During his rule, Rome had to contend with
two major wars, a rebellion, and a plague
that ravaged his empire.
Early Years & Rise to Power
Marcus Aurelius was born on April 26, 121
AD, to Marcus Annius Verus III and Domitia
Lucilla.
His name at birth may have also been Marcus
Annius Verus just like his father, grandfather,
and great-grandfather but, to avoid confusion,
we’ll just call him Marcus Aurelius from
the start.
His family was wealthy and relatively influential.
According to Cassius Dio, one of our main
sources for the reign of Marcus Aurelius,
his family was somehow related to Emperor
Hadrian.
Aurelius’s father was a politician who held
the office of praetor, but he died young when
Marcus was just a child.
We’re not sure on the exact date, but it
would have been around 124 AD while he was
still in office.
Later, Marcus Aurelius wrote that, while he
did not remember much of his father, from
what little memory he had of him plus what
other people have said, he characterized his
father by “modesty and manliness,” traits
that he sought to emulate.
As far as his mother was concerned, Aurelius
said that from her he learned “religious
piety, generosity, not only refraining from
wrongdoing but even from thoughts of it, simplicity
in diet, and to be far removed from the ways
of the rich.”
After his father’s death, Marcus Aurelius
and his sister, Annia Cornificia Faustina,
were adopted by their paternal grandfather,
Marcus Annius Verus II, who had been made
patrician during the reign of Vespasian.
His father had been a praetor and his grandfather
served three times as consul so, naturally,
it was expected for Marcus Aurelius to follow
in their footsteps.
In 127 AD, when he was just six years old,
he was enrolled in the equestrian order by
nomination of Emperor Hadrian himself.
Other than that, we do not have much information
about the early years of the future emperor,
apart from the names of some of his teachers
such as Diognetus and Alexander of Cotiaeum.
Later on, he was also tutored by Apollonius
of Chalcedon, the man who introduced him to
Stoicism, the philosophy that deeply influenced
all aspects of his life.
The story of Marcus Aurelius’s rise to power
is a bit convoluted, but I think we can get
there.
He was born during the reign of Hadrian, who
had no children of his own.
Therefore, when the emperor fell ill in 136
AD, he thought it would be a good idea to
appoint an heir.
He adopted Lucius Ceionius Commodus who, as
emperor-in-waiting, took the name Lucius Aelius.
However, this turned out to be an ill-fated
choice, as Aelius died at the start of 138
AD.
Next up, Hadrian adopted Antoninus Pius as
his heir, who became emperor later that same
year after Hadrian died on July 10.
As it happened, Antoninus was also Marcus
Aurelius’s uncle as he married Faustina,
his father’s sister.
Hadrian’s adoption of Antoninus came with
a few conditions.
In turn, Antoninus had to adopt the surviving
son of his predecessor, a seven-year-old boy
also named Lucius Ceionius Commodus, as well
as his own nephew, Marcus Aurelius.
All of a sudden, Aurelius was the eldest son
of the emperor, which meant that he was next
in line for the throne.
Some historians have speculated that this
had been Hadrian’s intention all along,
although why the emperor granted so much favor
to Aurelius, we’re not really sure.
Anyway, Antoninus was now the new Roman Emperor
and, to strengthen the bond with his newly
adopted son, he also had Marcus Aurelius marry
his natural born daughter, Faustina the Younger.
The two of them would go on to have 13 children
together.
Unsurprisingly, Marcus Aurelius’s position
as heir apparent brought with it a lot of
new promotions.
He was first made consul in 140.
He also became the head of the equestrian
order, he joined the colleges of priests,
he took up residence in the imperial palace,
and was made quaestor to learn about the paperwork
and oration that were needed to rule Rome.
The highest office he reached while Antoninus
was still emperor was praetorian prefect.
At one point, he also changed his name to
Marcus Aelius Aurelius Verus Caesar, but we
will keep referring to him simply as Marcus
Aurelius for simplicity’s sake.
Meanwhile, his adopted brother took on the
name Lucius Verus and followed a similar path,
serving both as quaestor and consul.
One notable difference between them was their
physical prowess.
Marcus Aurelius was “frail in body,” as
Cassius Dio put it, while Verus was “a vigorous
man of younger years” who was proficient
in hunting and wrestling, but took pleasure
in all athletic pursuits.
Around 160 AD, Antoninus fell ill.
He died the following year at his ancestral
home in Lorium, ending what was then the second-longest
reign of the Roman Empire after that of Augustus.
A few days later, he was deified at the request
of his sons.
In his book, Marcus Aurelius spoke very fondly
of his adoptive father, saying that no other
man had more influence on him as a youth.
“The king is dead, long live the king,”
as the expression goes.
Antoninus was gone and Rome needed an emperor.
The Senate was ready to confirm Marcus Aurelius
as the new sovereign, but something curious
happened.
Marcus Aurelius refused to take office unless
his younger brother, Lucius Verus, was made
co-emperor alongside him.
It was unusual, but the Senate accepted and
March 8, 161 AD, marked the first time that
the Roman Empire was ruled by two men.
That being said, it was never in question
who the true leader of Rome was.
Besides the fact that Marcus Aurelius was
the chosen heir, he was also the older sibling,
he had experience helping Antoninus run the
empire, and he was the only one with the title
of Pontifex Maximus.
Verus obeyed Marcus “as a lieutenant obeys
a proconsul.”
You might think this is a setup for some kind
of conspiracy, or betrayal, or even assassination
down the line.
That’s usually how these situations unfolded
in ancient times, but we have here a rare
exception.
Despite their different personalities, the
brothers stayed on good terms for the extent
of their joint rule and never did one of them
try to usurp the other.
The War in Parthia
You might think that the rule of a calm, practical,
and amiable man would mark a time of peace
for the Roman Empire, but that was not to
be.
In fact, almost for his entire 19-year reign,
Marcus Aurelius was involved in one conflict
or another.
First up was the Parthian Empire, a mighty
Middle Eastern faction that had been around
since the 3rd century BC.
This was not the first time that these two
powers clashed.
It seemed that every time the Parthians wanted
to expand to the west, they eventually ran
into the dominion of Rome.
This usually took the form of the Kingdom
of Armenia, a land that acted as a buffer
between the two empires who both wanted to
install an Armenian king who served their
best interests.
The last time this happened was during the
rule of Trajan who we already covered here
on Biographics.
If you need a quick refresher on him, why
not check the video in the link below.
That happened almost 50 years before Marcus
Aurelius became emperor and, in the end, Armenia
became a client state of Rome with its king
firmly under Roman control.
It seems that every few decades, a new Parthian
king gets the same idea - to remove Armenia
from under Roman influence and place it under
Parthian influence.
In this case, it was King Vologases IV.
In 161 AD, he marched into Armenia and deposed
King Sohaemus, replacing him with his own
son, Pacorus.
The Romans were clearly taken by surprise
by this move and their initial reply was disastrous.
There were two Roman provinces that bordered
the Kingdom of Armenia: Cappadocia and Syria.
Marcus Sedatius Severianus, the Governor of
Cappadocia, decided to take matters into his
own hands, even though he was not supposed
to act without instructions from the emperor.
Allegedly, an oracle convinced him that he
would overpower the Parthians so he took a
legion and marched into Armenia.
He reached Elegeia where his entire army was
surrounded and massacred.
As for Severianus himself, he was either killed
along with his soldiers or he committed suicide
once he realized how badly he had been defeated.
Seizing the upper hand, the Parthians then
invaded Syria and bested the Romans there,
as well.
The first wave of the war went decidedly in
the Parthians’ favor and it didn’t look
like things were going to get better for the
Romans.
They were led by two emperors who were completely
inexperienced in military matters.
They also had threats to deal with in other
frontier provinces such as Britain and Germania
Superior.
Moreover, the defeat and subsequent retreat
of the Roman forces in Syria created perfect
conditions for a rebellion.
Eventually, Marcus Aurelius decided that Lucius
Verus should go in person to guide the war
against Parthia.
If anyone was expecting Verus to be a great,
inspiring commander, this was the moment that
did away with that notion.
As it turned out, Verus was the type of leader
who preferred to pursue earthly delights and
let others do the fighting for him.
Allegedly, he spent most of the Parthian campaign
at a resort in Antioch where he feasted and
gambled daily, surrounded by his entourage.
As it said in the Historia Augusta: “...while
legions were being slaughtered, while Syria
medidated revolt, and the East was being devastated,
Verus was hunting in Apulia, travelling about
through Athens and Corinth accompanied by
orchestras and singers.”
At this time, we should also point out that
the veracity of the Historia Augusta is highly
uncertain so don’t take anything from it
as absolute truth.
For his part, Cassius Dio confirmed that Verus
made his headquarters in Antioch and didn’t
personally take part in any battles, but made
no mention of his party lifestyle.
Whatever the truth, fortunately for Rome,
there were also a few capable generals who
left with Verus and continued on their way
to Parthia.
Some of the more important ones were Martius
Verus, Statius Priscus, and Avidius Cassius.
Remember that last one as he will be important
later.
Martius Verus attacked Armenia and conquered
the capital of Artaxata.
He then restored Sohaemus to the throne, the
previous king who was subservient to Rome,
and assumed the governorship of Cappadocia.
Historian Cassius Dio gives most of the credit
for the eventual Roman victory to Avidius
Cassius.
After King Vologases retreated back to Parthia,
he gave chase, and in 166 AD they sacked the
cities of Seleucia and Ctesiphon, the latter
being the Parthian capital.
Afterwards, Avidius made his way to Syria
where he eliminated any threat of a rebellion
and was installed as the new governor of the
province.
Later, Marcus Aurelius would grant him control
over all the Roman territories in Asia, a
decision he would come
to regret.
The Antonine Plague
Despite just winning a war, things soon went
from bad to worse for the Roman Empire.
The soldiers returning home did not come alone.
They brought with them a mysterious illness
that started one of the first known pandemics
in history.
It became known as the Antonine Plague, also
known as the Plague of Galen, named after
the Greek physician who described the disease
and its symptoms in his treatise Methodus
Medendi.
It caused fever, vomiting, swollen throat,
diarrhea, thirstiness, and violent coughing
fits that produced a foul odor and skin rashes
all over the body.
The illness lasted for about two weeks and
the ones fortunate enough to survive it became
immune from further infection.
The exact nature of the disease is still somewhat
of a mystery.
Smallpox and measles were generally regarded
as the most likely culprits, both capable
of ravaging a population that had no resistance
to them whatsoever.
In more recent times, the second candidate
has fallen out of favor and both scholars
and doctors believe smallpox was the true
cause of the plague.
They point to archaeological evidence that
depict people infected with the illness displaying
the pustules typically associated with smallpox.
While the Romans picked up the plague while
campaigning in Parthia, the exact origins
are shrouded in legend.
There are multiple versions of the story,
but they all seem to suggest that the disease
was punishment from the gods because the Romans
allegedly broke an oath they made not to pillage
the city of Seleucia.
Trying to determine the impact of the pandemic
with accuracy is impossible.
Some say it wasn’t as bad as everyone thinks
and that it demonstrated the resilience of
Rome, while others believe it marked the beginning
of the fall of the Western Roman Empire.
At its height, it killed thousands of people
a day as it spread throughout all the Roman
territories.
It lasted until 180 AD and some believe that
the Plague of Cyprian which appeared 70 years
later was, in fact, another outbreak of the
same illness.
Lastly, the Antonine Plague may have claimed
the life of Lucius Verus.
While we don’t have details surrounding
his demise, Verus fell ill in 169 AD and died
on January 23, leaving Marcus Aurelius as
the sole Emperor of Rome.
The Marcomannic Wars
The Antonine Plague was just one of the crises
that Marcus Aurelius had to contend with following
the end of the Parthian War.
The other one was barbarian invasions by Germanic
peoples along its northern frontier which
was also known as Limes Germanicus.
Such border conflicts were relatively common
for the Romans and represented an almost-constant
threat to their outermost provinces.
In fact, when the enemy was strong and determined
enough, they represented a threat to Rome
itself as just a few centuries later, the
heart of the empire was sacked multiple times
by invading Goths and Vandals.
The situation was not as dire this time around,
but the Roman Empire was clearly at a disadvantage.
It had just finished a war, meaning that its
coffers were getting empty and its people
were growing weary of conflict.
Most of its northern border was poorly defended
because the troops had been redirected to
Parthia.
And last, but certainly by no means least,
there was the plague to deal with.
It certainly seemed like an opportune time
to attack, but scholars are still debating
over the exact motive for the invasion.
Some believe that the most obvious answer
is true - the Germanic tribes simply sought
to take advantage of the weakened state of
the Roman Empire.
Others speculate that it might have been overpopulation
or another threat from the East which forced
them to expand into the West.
The main belligerents (besides the Romans,
of course) were the Germanic Marcomanni, hence
the name Marcomannic Wars.
They were joined by another Germanic tribe
called the Quadi, and the Iazyges, who were
actually a Sarmatian people originating in
the steppes of Eurasia.
They were assisted, at various points, by
other tribes as the Marcomannic Wars were
a major conflict that lasted for almost two
decades and extended into the reign of Marcus
Aurelius’s successor.
The leader of the opposing forces was Ballomar,
King of the Marcomanni.
Cassius Dio first mentions him for acting
as mediator following some barbarian skirmishes
into Roman territory.
This happened in the years shortly before
the outbreak of the war and involved other
Germanic tribes such as the Longobards and
the Ubii on one side and Marcus Jallius Bassus,
then-governor of the Roman province of Pannonia
Inferior, on the other.
What exactly persuaded Ballomar to turn from
conciliator to aggressor, we don’t know,
but in 166 AD he united several tribes and
crossed the Danube to lead incursions into
Roman territory.
Because of the other problems in the empire,
it wasn’t until 168 that Marcus Aurelius
was ready to respond.
The Roman army marched to Pannonia and set
up a base at Aquileia.
This time, both emperors were there to lead
the troops.
According to the Historia Augusta, many tribal
leaders immediately started retreating or
asking for pardons.
For a while, it seemed like this conflict
would fizzle out as soon as it started, but
Marcus Aurelius was concerned that this was
all a ploy to stall for time.
He wanted to keep pursuing the enemy, but
this was when Lucius Verus fell ill and died.
The remaining emperor had to return to Rome
to make preparations for his brother’s funeral.
Marcus Aurelius returned to the battlefield
later that same year, accompanied by his general
and son-in-law Claudius Pompeianus.
A little sidenote here: Cassius Dio singled
out Pompeianus as the military commander who
distinguished himself the most during the
Marcomannic Wars, alongside another lieutenant
named Pertinax who would go on to become emperor
during one of the most tumultuous periods
in Roman history, but that’s a story for
another time.
For now, we see the barbarian tribes gaining
the upper hand in the war.
The Iazyges invaded the provinces of Moesia
and Dacia and killed the governor Claudius
Fronto who served as general during the Parthian
War.
Other tribes went into Greece and destroyed
one of the most important religious sites
in the Roman Empire, the Temple of Eleusinian
Mysteries.
But the Marcomanni were the most dangerous
of all.
They scored a decisive victory at Carnuntum
in 170 AD where they faced off against an
inexperienced Roman army and slain 20,000
soldiers.
They kept pushing until they reached Italy
itself, marking the first time in over 270
years that an enemy of Rome managed to penetrate
into the heart of the empire.
Marcus Aurelius realized that the Marcomanni
posed the greatest threat and considered them
a priority when launching a counter-offensive.
Legions from other frontiers were rerouted
to fight Ballomar and this strategy proved
successful.
By the end of 171 AD, they had pushed the
Marcomanni out of Roman territory and continued
their pursuit across the Danube until the
Marcomanni were defeated.
The other, smaller tribes began seeking audiences
with Marcus Aurelius.
Some of them surrendered, others offered alliances.
The Quadi agreed to a peace treaty, but then
broke it and went to war again.
Aurelius defeated them once more and installed
a pro-Roman king called Furtius, but the Quadi
deposed him and renewed hostilities yet again.
The two sides met in battle and the Quadi
would have defeated the Romans if not for
divine intervention, according to Cassius
Dio, at least.
He says that one of Marcus Aurelius’s retinue,
an Egyptian magician called Arnuphis, prayed
to Mercury and summoned a storm.
While the Romans were reinvigorated by the
pouring rain, the Quadi were struck by lightning
and engulfed in flames.
Nothing as dramatic happened with the Iazyges.
They simply surrendered and their King Zanticus
agreed to the terms set by Marcus Aurelius.
The emperor’s triumphs are recorded on the
Column of Marcus Aurelius still located in
the Piazza Colonna in Rome.
It was modeled on the triumphal column of
Trajan who celebrated his victories over the
Dacians.
Also during his years in battle, Marcus Aurelius
started writing down his personal philosophies
which formed the basis for one of the most
influential works on Stoicism.
Even today, his book titled Meditations is
still a popular seller, although the emperor
never intended it to be published.
Some argue that he wrote it for himself, others
that it was for his sons.
Going back to the battle, this was only the
First Marcomannic War.
It was the biggest of them all, but it was
followed by two more.
It has been speculated that Marcus Aurelius
had grander ambitions and might have wanted
to eliminate the threat permanently during
the first war and establish new Roman provinces.
However, he had little choice but to accept
quick victories and peace treaties.
His attention was needed elsewhere as trouble
was brewing in Syria.
A New Emperor Rises
Remember Avidius Cassius, the general from
the Parthian War who was in charge of Syria
and the surrounding provinces?
Well, in 175 AD, he decided to rise against
Marcus Aurelius and declare himself the new
Emperor of Rome.
While there is controversy surrounding his
motives, he did it because word had reached
him that Aurelius had died during the Marcomannic
War.
Even more controversially, historian Cassius
Dio pointed the finger at Faustina, the emperor’s
wife, as being the one who engineered this
deception.
Allegedly, she also believed that her husband
would die in the war and feared that an outsider
would kill her son to take the throne by force.
Therefore, she preferred Cassius as emperor
because he would not take such drastic measures.
Anyway, Cassius eventually found out that
Marcus Aurelius was still alive but, by then,
it was too late to go back.
Well, actually, it might not have been if
we’re going by Dio again.
He portrayed Marcus Aurelius as one of the
most gracious Roman emperors in history because
he was not only willing to forgive the man
who was once one of his strongest allies,
but also said in a speech that if the soldiers,
Senate, and people of Rome preferred Cassius
over him, he would surrender his power without
struggle.
Of course, this may have all simply been a
way of rallying the troops to his side.
After all, what Marcus Aurelius actually did
was end the Marcomannic War as fast as possible
and head to Asia with his army.
Meanwhile, Cassius was raising his own force,
but a battle between the two never took place.
Just three months after the rebellion started,
General Cassius was assassinated by his own
men who were still loyal to the true emperor.
His head was brought to Marcus Aurelius, but
he allegedly refused to see it and ordered
to have it buried.
Whether or not Faustina was involved in the
plot remains uncertain, but she also died
that same year.
Regardless of her intentions, her husband
remained devoted to her and deified her and
gave her a lavish funeral.
With the rebellion over, Marcus Aurelius was
finally able to return to Rome where he had
his son, Commodus, named co-emperor.
Initially, he intended two of his sons to
rule the empire as he did with Lucius Verus,
but his other heir, Annius Verus, died when
he was a boy.
Peace was brief as the emperor had to leave
in 177 to fight in the Second Marcomannic
War.
He would never return to Rome again as he
died on March 17, 180, at Vindobona, modern
day Vienna.
He was 58 years old and, although he was seemingly
a man who cherished wisdom and eudaimonia,
he was forced to spend almost his entire reign
plunged into war and chaos.
He was followed by his son Commodus who was
the antithesis of his father - cruel, vain,
merciless, debauched, inept, and a complete
megalomaniac.
Never again would mighty Rome reach the same
heights.
As Cassius Dio put it, after the death of
Marcus Aurelius, the empire descended “from
a kingdom of gold to one of iron and rust.”